today on the matt walsh show president
biden delivers a long rambling at times
barely intelligible speech to congress
last night but if you could stay awake
and decipher it there was plenty to be
concerned about especially the part
where biden unveils his plan for
universal preschool i'll explain why
that's a horrible
dystopian idea also five headlines
including the parents who are
volunteering their babies for
covid vaccine trials what sort of parent
would do that and a track run or an
organ
collapses on the track after being
forced to run with a mask plus is the
no-fly list
being politically weaponized by the
bidet administration
we'll deal with that and finally in our
daily cancellation we'll talk about the
um the outrage over comments made by
steve harvey claiming
that men and women cannot be platonic
friends is he wrong
or is he exactly 100 correct all of that
and more today on the matt wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
the problem with state of the union
addresses or
speeches to a joint session of congress
which is the same thing
is that they're always dull and
pointless and forgotten by everyone
35 minutes after they conclude they make
no difference they leave no lasting mark
and they achieve nothing it is an
occasion for our political elites to
engage in empty
self-congratulatory pageantry sort of
like the oscars but for presidents
not incidentally they also tend to be as
boring as the oscars and to generate
about the same level of viewer
enthusiasm
enthusiasm which hovers somewhere in
between dazed confused
and catatonic and of course that also
happens to describe the general demeanor
of our president credit where it's due
though
biden's speech did at least manage to up
the ante and be even more grotesque
and depressing than the average speech
of this sort last night biden delivered
his address to a half-empty room
of socially distanced fully vaccinated
politicians in masks
it all looked quite creepy and dystopian
like a masquerade ball from hell
or something now if congressional
republicans had any sense or backbone
they would have refused to participate
in the farce instead they sat there
masked and obedient clapping on cue
now imagine if republicans had refused
to wear the masks on the reasonable
ground that
they're all vaccinated and the masks
serve therefore no effective purpose
would they have been kicked out of the
room would they have been arrested
or would they been allowed to sit there
maskless and free as men and women of
dignity
whatever the case it would have been a
major political win
there would have been no way to lose
politically
had the republicans refused to take part
in the masking sham the only way to lose
was to do exactly what the democrats
told them to do and as always
republicans surveyed the options and
quickly chose the one
where they gain nothing lose everything
and the other side wins
they're nothing if not consistent now
the speech itself
was lengthy and drawn out but also moved
quickly from one topic to the next in a
mostly disjointed fashion
listening to it was like being stuck in
some sort of disorienting time warp it
felt like it was moving quickly but also
not moving at all
biden kicked things off by claiming that
the january sixth riot was the worst
attack on our democracy since
the civil war now some might say that
911 was at least
slightly worse than a crowd of people
briefly trespassing in the capital
in one case 3 000 people were
slaughtered and the other only one
person
was directly killed in the melee and
that was one of the people in the crowd
who was shot dead while while unarmed by
a still unnamed capital police officer
indeed some might say that there have
been countless attacks and tragedies
between 1865 and 2021
that were far worse in scope scale and
body count than january 6th
even the blm riots before and after that
event
were worse by all of those measures and
it's not even close
but biden's speech was based in a
reality that is not the one that we all
live in
case in point he also pledged to cure
cancer and promise to devote trillions
of dollars to
an infinite array of programs and causes
this is just not a serious man it was
not a serious speech
though his agenda or the agenda of his
handlers does pose a serious threat
but the most frightening part of biden's
rambling half whispered diatribe
came at the very beginning when he
unveiled his 1.8 trillion dollar
american families plan because he's got
a plan for you
for your family which is supposed to
guarantee paid leave free community
college free day care
free waffles for every man woman and
child in the country
it also includes an item long on the
leftist
wish list which is universal preschool
listen to this
the great universities in this country
have conducted studies of the
last 10 years it shows that adding two
years of universal high quality
preschool
for every three-year-old and
four-year-old no matter what background
they come from
puts them in the position to be able to
compete
all the way through 12 years and
increases exponentially their
prospect of graduating and going on
beyond graduation
the research chose when a young child
goes to school not
daycare they're far more likely to
graduate from high school
and go to college or something
after high school when you add two years
of free community
college on top of that you begin to
change
the dynamic yes send your three-year-old
to school not
daycare you irresponsible parents now in
fact as publications from the atlantic
to the washington post of the heritage
foundation
have all argued universal preschool does
not live up to the promises that biden
makes for it
in the long run studies show that it can
do more academic harm than good
but the real problem with the universal
preschool plan is deeper and more
fundamental than that
biden says that if we get children into
the government education system starting
at the age of three
they'll be able to better compete and
ultimately their prospects of going to
college will improve
now this is an idea rooted in a
materialistic
utilitarian view of the human person
people are not people
so much as cogs to be molded into the
correct shape
and fit into their appointed place in
the machine
the strategy doesn't even really achieve
that desired end but
that's almost beside the point what sort
of parent is worried about their
three-year-old competing
competing against who my youngest son is
four and
i've never once given even a moment's
thought
to whether i'm currently equipping him
with all the tools he needs to compete
in the global marketplace
he's a child his job now
is to be a child my job is to see to his
basic needs while attending also to his
moral spiritual and emotional formation
at no point have i even considered what
his college application might look like
one day
or how his professional resume is coming
together
i am concerned with teaching him yeah
but but for children at his age
preschool age we call it now the best
way for them to learn is not by sitting
in a classroom
but by playing and exploring
you know playing for for a young child
that's serious business
that's where they do most of their
learning and developing
it's ultimately harmful to a child's
development to place competitive
pressure on them
that early young children should feel
only the mild pressure to you know clean
up their toys and uh finish their
broccoli
they should be thinking about their
future s.a.t scores
for god's sake but then again i'm
approaching this
right from the standpoint of a parent
that is i love my children and i want
them to be happy and i want them to grow
into good and well-adjusted human beings
that's my desire for them as a parent
the government for all of its nanny
state talk
for all that for all of for all of its
talk where it makes itself
sound like it's a parent uh it doesn't
actually love
my children or yours and doesn't care
about spiritual and
emotional and moral growth development
or anything else
the government sees your child as
property
to be owned and used that's why joe
biden there says no no
your thrill doesn't belong in in daycare
your three-year-old belongs with us give
him to me
now the government's objective is to
ensure that your child becomes the sort
of person
that it needs him to be and thinks he
ought to be
the brainwashing has to start early
that of course is not just a matter of
fitting them into the global marketplace
but it is about turning
making sure from the government's
perspective that your child has
the correct quote unquote values
and beliefs and we've got a pretty good
idea of what those values and beliefs
are
you get them in there at three you start
them on the gender indoctrination you
start them on critical race there you
get that in
very very early so early that
the child stands no chance of resisting
it
three-year-old has no critical thinking
skills almost at all
so whatever you tell them they'll
believe
and the government knows that that
objective is better served and can more
effectively be fulfilled if the children
are sent into its clutches at the
youngest possible age
children once began school in
kindergarten you know
and then we added pre-k and then
pre-pre-k
and soon pre-pre pre pre-k and then you
know then you get pre-pre
pre pre-k and it just goes on and on and
on
this cannot be best for your child it's
not
what's best for him is to be at home
with you
not sent into government buildings
almost immediately after birth
but the government is not concerned
about what's best for him
they're concerned about how they can use
him
and how they can best turn him into the
sort of person
they think he should be
and that is why preschool is canceled oh
wait no that's
that's the segment at the end of the
show but either way uh
universal preschool is a terrible idea
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know i did have to uh by the way
mentioned at the top of the monologue
uh specify that they talk about state of
union addresses
state of the union address or a joint
speech to congress
speech to a joint session of congress
it's really important to um
stipulate that because of all the
pedantic a-holes out there in internet
land which is the
the one thing i think i hate most about
the internet we all do so like for
example i i tweeted yesterday
uh last night about exactly what i said
that every state of the union address is
pointless and is forgotten by everyone
the next day which is true
i mean can you remember anything that a
president said in any state of union
address
in the past uh i certainly don't and but
the comments under that tweet was just
nothing but
one comment after another this was not a
state of the union address it was an
annual message
state of the union will be in january
matt this was an address to congress
just fyi not a state of the union
then what this wasn't a state of the
union address one comment
what state of the union address this
wasn't that lol
this wasn't a state of the union speech
genius
and it's like no it is it is it's
exactly
the same thing it's just a different
name sometimes presidents and they're
for
this this started somewhat recently the
last few presidents their first
state of the union address they choose
to call it something else
for political reasons mostly i don't
know what exactly those political
reasons are
probably has a lot to do with well i
just got here so
usually state of the union address i'm
going to look back on the past year and
say what a great job i did but i just
got here and i don't want to say the
last guy did a great job
so this is going to be a slightly
different thing politically
people this is how you could tell is a
good iq test when people
they have nothing of value to add to a
conversation
so all they can do is leap in with a
pedantic
useless uh redundant correction
that's how you can tell everyone who
does that they're sub 100 iqs
all right um but thank you for to
everyone who's
felt the need to correct me on that
point senator tim scott gave his
rebuttal to
biden's speech last night it was it was
fine
uh mostly it was a you know decent
speech
tim scott seems to be a decent guy
he talked about how america isn't racist
which is which is a good
thing to talk about and he was attacked
for that and called racial slurs by the
left
ironically but that of course also was
expected
let's uh let's listen to that part here
he is explaining how
america is not a racist country here's
tim scott
a hundred years ago kids in classrooms
were taught the color of their skin was
their most
important characteristic and if they
looked a certain way
they were inferior today cues are being
taught
that the color of their skin defines
them again
and if they look a certain way they're
an oppressor
from colleges to corporations to our
culture people are making money
and gaining power by pretending we
haven't made any progress
at all by doubling down on the divisions
we've worked so hard to heal you know
this stuff is wrong
hear me clearly america
is not a racist country
it's backwards to fight discrimination
with
different types of discrimination and
it's wrong
to try to use our painful paths to
dishonestly
shut down debates in the present
fine good no no problem there
but um we as conservatives were so
desperate you know for republicans
who are not milquetoast cowards that
were very very easy to impress
and so we hear something like that and
everybody a lot of conservatives
yesterday were
on their feet cheering yes finally
someone said it
america's not a racist country well yeah
of course i would hope he would at least
say that that's that's
that bar the bar is not even off the
ground yet
in terms of the standard are we really
at a point now where we're impressed
whenever
when a republican simply says america's
not a racist country
that's a sad statement and i guess it's
a statement about
the the the republican party generally
that we're impressed by something like
that
but it's not actually impressive yeah i
think i think we need to expect more
than that
uh and unfortunately a lot of the good
stuff
was undermined and the reason why i
can't give tim scott anything close to
an a plus grade
is because for one you know the gop
needs someone out front
in the lead who is to my mind
aggressive fiery someone who goes on the
offense
but most of scott's speech was defensive
and that's not just him as republicans
again in general
it's a defensive speech what you just
heard there about america is not racist
true good thing to point out but also a
defensive statement
but then worst of all um there was
this where he starts to talk about the
need for police reform let's listen
believe me i know firsthand our healing
is not finished in 2015
after the shooting of walter scott i
wrote a bill to fund body cameras
last year after the deaths of brianna
taylor and george floyd
i built an even bigger police reform
proposal
but my democratic colleagues blocked it
i extended an olive branch
i offered amendments but democrats used
a filibuster
to block the debate from even happening
my friends across the aisle seemed to
want the issue
more than they wanted a solution but i'm
still working
i'm hopeful that this will be different
yeah
and that's another uh thing tried and
true
from the republican playbook is to
rather than
taking issue on on a fundamental
like principle based level with what the
left is trying to do
instead you agree with the fundamental
principle and then you say
oh no we we agree with the left that
this
this or that thing needs to happen but
we're the ones who are better at making
that thing happen
so the argument essentially is um we're
we are a more effective version
of leftists we're more we're leftists
too but we're effective leftists
that's the selling point we get from the
republican party that's a selling point
we get from
supposed conservatives that's what you
just heard there
he's saying hey i want to i'm i i think
there needs to be federal police reform
too
police reform on the federal level but
uh we we're the one
we're trying harder than them to reform
the police
no what we need to hear is here's what
we need to hear
the push for police reform is based on a
fantasy it is based on a falsehood it is
based on a myth
it is based entirely this this push
right now for police reform
is based entirely on the idea
that there is an epidemic of race-based
police brutality
that's what that's why we're talking
about police reform everyone knows that
well that is false it's not real it's
made up it's not a real epidemic
the facts don't line up with that that's
a false narrative
that's what we need to hear i would love
to hear someone like tim scott
tim scott any any republican given that
kind of stage
stand up there and give the statistics
tell people the truth
about what's really going on
talk about the number of police
shootings compared to the number of
arrests
how many of them are unarmed
the fact that the vast vast vast
majority police shootings
are are straightforwardly
valid and legitimate because you've got
a a violent per
perp trying to murder a police officer
usually usually shooting at them and
that's
and then they get shot back that's like
the majority of police shootings talk
about that
how about defend specifically you know
some of these specific officers
the officer in the micaiah bryant um
shooting for example
but that's what the push for police
reform is based on
now we that's that's not the problem
right now in our cities is not that we
have police
uh precincts and police departments that
are
unreformed that's not what we need
we don't need police reform we don't
need criminal justice reform in the way
that the
democrats talk about it and the way the
republicans do
what we need are are better ways
to get violent criminals off the street
and keep them off
because as that's the kind of reform we
need want a criminal justice reform
that's it
because there are hundreds thousands of
violent criminals walking around our
cities right now who are known to the
system have already been
through the system have already been
arrested a bunch of times
are known to be violent threats they
filter through they're put back out into
the community
they keep committing crimes they go back
in until finally they do something so
heinous that
there's no choice but to put them away
for good
that's the kind of reform we need
enforcing the law getting dangerous
people
out of society better protecting society
i'd love to hear that from the
republicans
instead we get police reform which again
is a democrat idea
democrats are the ones who told us we
need police reform and then tim scott
and others say
all right great idea i'll do a better
job than you
all right number two if you want to feel
your skin crawl always a fun sensation
let me play some clips from an abc
report about parents who've offered
their kids up to be lab rats
in vaccine trials so
as it stands right now of course kids
are not eligible for the vaccine
but they've got to you know do do
trials on kids and so there are parents
out there
willingly offering their kids up and
saying sure
try this uh inject this substance into
my child
we'll see what happens so let's watch a
little bit of this report
today kids as young as six months old
are taking part in trials for both
moderna
and pfizer's covid19 vaccines with their
parents consent
far far away dr zena good enrolled
both her sons in stanford hospital's
pfizer trial
so we thought participating is a really
good way to
protect our kids and uh so far because
this
vaccine has been tested in a lot of
teenagers and all so many adults and it
was
shown very safe we felt pretty
comfortable to participate
seven-month-old soarin one of the
youngest in the trial
received his first shot last week mom
says he's doing well
his older brother three-year-old ando
also got the shot
did he experience any side effects from
the vaccine he had a sore
arm for like for a day and was a little
bit low on energy for like a day but
that's not um we're not sure it's even
side effects he might have just
you know been tired that morning okay
well you know what what makes this to me
so heinous
is that this is uh
an illness that doesn't affect kids
anyway
now if this was an illness that affected
kids uh i
i still probably wouldn't be putting my
kids up in line to be to be first
uh but at least you could say you know
there's a there's a potential advantage
to your child that this is an illness
that affects kids and you're worried
about your kids health and so you want
to get them
the vaccine as quickly as possible uh
and and the risks are low and all of
that
so maybe you could make an argument
there but in this case it's
it's not your your child these children
a baby
are at almost no risk already
so you're introducing a risk for no
reason
offering them up to be to be
experimented on
to be lab rats in a vaccine trial for a
virus that wouldn't really affect them
anyway
most of the time here's another parent
and i want you to listen to her
reasoning
i thought was pretty telling here she is
i think it's a three-year-old child
explaining why she put her
three-year-old up to be
experimented on with the vaccine here it
is dr angela lacour's three-year-old
daughter is also in the trial
how about that that's it look at you
brave kid gosh you are the brave
she says she feels strongly that doing
this isn't just about keeping
her child safe we're just so lucky that
we have
a healthy child um and so grateful that
she's able to be part of this
but i think knowing that there are so
many other parents out there whose
children
are vulnerable and and may struggling
and they're really waiting for the
vaccine to become a reality
her being able to be part of this and
make that as a reality for other
families and
as a mom i can't imagine what that fear
must be like for them
we're just so proud of her outside of a
fever
a rash at the injection site did they
talk to you about any potential side
effects
i know that in very extreme and rare
circumstances like they couldn't even
give us a rate for this there's the risk
of anaphylaxis
and again she hasn't had any kind of
reaction to other vaccines so
not something i was very concerned about
but it also brought us a lot of comfort
that we were doing this across the
street from the hospital
yeah uh so she says
we're grateful that we have a healthy
child and so we're going to offer her up
here
um because of other kids
and we're looking out for other kids
well that may seem
magnanimous and generous but the problem
is it's
it's your kids if you were offering
yourself up your own body
as a as a as a um you know a vessel for
experimentation
with the vaccine then i could say okay
very brave of you i can appreciate that
but it's not you though it's your child
and they didn't consent to this they
can't have consent she's only three
years old
there's no way she could have consented
you might have told her oh honey we're
gonna bring you in and give you a shot
and uh and then you'll get a sticker
we'll take out for ice cream and i'm
sure the kid will say oh it sounds great
yeah let's do it mommy
but they have no idea what they're doing
or what the potential side effects are
nobody really knows exactly what the
side effects are on kids that's why
we're doing trials right now
so they didn't consent can't consent and
you're offering them up for the sake of
other children that is
totally disordered and backwards upside
down topsy-turvy okay that's not as
as apparent your first priority is your
own
child's safety always
you never put your own child's safety
below you know the the uh
the welfare of other children it's good
to be concerned about the welfare of
all children but your first concern is
the child that god gave to you
and just to potentially sacrifice that
welfare or to put it on the line for the
sake of the welfare of someone else's
child
is completely disordered all right next
nick fuentes
says that he tried to board a plane this
week only to discover that he was
on the no-fly list and later he
published a video of himself
talking to a southwest agent i think
with southwest who tells him
in the video that he can't fly with them
and he needs to talk to
tsa about it which seems to confirm
or at least provide good evidence that
he is indeed on some kind of no-fly
lessons it's not just
a matter of one airline saying you can't
board for this or that reason
um now anyone who who has listened to
this show for a while knows that nick
fuentes and i
have not seen eye to eye to put it
mildly but here's the thing you don't
have to see eye to eye with a person
you don't have to agree with them about
everything or anything at all in order
to be
very very troubled at the prospect the
possibility
that people are being put on a no-fly
list because of their political
viewpoints
their ideological viewpoints
i mean no matter it doesn't matter how
you feel about those views
nick fuentes hasn't been convicted of
any crime he hasn't been charged with
any crime
he was at the capitol on january 6th but
he says he was never in the building
never entered the building hasn't been
charged with entering it
now the thing about the no fly list is
that um you aren't gonna know exactly
why you're on it so you could say well
maybe there's a good reason
well so we're supposed to just trust
the government when they say that that's
the problem they don't tell you why
you're on it
they don't even tell you that you're on
it you have to go and try to fly
like what happened in this case you have
to try to get on a plane and that's when
you find out
and even then they won't tell you
everything
so for me this is kind of easy um
i i don't think i don't think the no-fly
should exist at all i don't think anyone
should be on it
if the government can prove that you're
a dangerous criminal they should convict
you
um of of of that crime and
and punish you for it but if they can't
prove it
if they can't even muster enough
evidence to charge you with a crime
okay again this is a punishment no fly
loss is a punishment
imposed on people not only before
they've been
convicted of a crime but before they've
even been
charged with any crime or accused of any
crime
the government can still say you're not
allowed to fly
we're not going to tell you why we're
not going to necessarily give you any
process to get off of it
with the no files they can restrict your
movement without any burden of proof
just by they just bypass the bill of
rights entirely that's a problem
and it's a power begging to be abused
it's an abusive power by its own nature
and it and it can be abused further
and wielded as a political weapon which
perhaps now this is exactly what this
administration is doing
and it could happen anybody the guy that
nick point this could happen anybody
and if you're on the right what you also
have to keep in mind um
is that the powers that be
democrats and leftists they don't draw
any distinction
between anybody on the right
they've got the category of the right
and everyone is the same
they don't draw any distinction between
any of them so anything you see
happening
to one person in that category can
happen to everybody
whether they're being de-platformed
kicked off social media
put on no fly list
that can happen to everybody i mean just
think about think about if there was a
what if there was a no drive list think
about that because i
one of the excuses i've heard this in
relation to the nick fuentes thing
um even even even conservatives i i've
heard say
uh that well flying flying isn't a right
yeah it's not a constitutionally
guaranteed right but that doesn't mean
that the government can
take it away without any justification
at all
is that what we're saying if a right is
not guaranteed and listed
in the bill of rights specifically then
the government can can take it away for
any reason without any justification
without any
uh uh accountability transparency is
that really the road we want to go down
and as far as going down roads yeah
imagine a no drive list driving also is
not a guaranteed right in the
constitution
um but what if you got
pulled over because you're like your
license plate was flagged
and the cop told you oh sorry you're on
a no drive list you're not allowed to
drive
you haven't been convicted you know you
haven't been convicted of a crime you
haven't been accused of a crime
you weren't drunk driving nothing like
that you just you got on a list somehow
maybe because of your political views
you've been you've been deemed a threat
for reasons that are unclear and now
they say you can't drive and not only
can you not drive
you can't even be a passenger on the
road
we know there are people who get their
licenses taken away but that's for a
reason there's a reason for it
and you have a process through the court
system to rectify it if a mistake was
made
or if you believe you're innocent or
whatever
would anyone accept that a no drive list
that functions that way then why do we
accept it with a no-fly list
and you can't say that oh flying is is
more dangerous so it's a different kind
of thing
it's not driving is a hell of a lot more
dangerous and a hell of a lot more
people die doing it
so they can do with with the planes they
can do it with uh
cars do with any vehicle
why not all right um
moving on finally let's lighten the mood
a little bit here
i don't know if this is going to lighten
the mood or just send you plunging
finally into the abyss of depression
it'll do
one or the other but um you know i got
to play
this for you and i'm not even going to
go to intro it but but
here it is from our friends at tick tock
here it is hiya fizer
hi ben you got any extra shots sure ben
sleeves up
[Music]
with my vaccinations
[Music]
oh we're having so much fun we'll have
to do this again for my second shot
oh i love you ben
you know that you know um
you know these uh super volcanoes that
you
they're across across the earth and uh
scientists say that a super volcano
could go off anytime
and spew so much molten ash into the air
sends us into an eternal night kills all
life on the planet
it sounded kind of good right about now
i got to play one more i'm sorry i don't
know why i'm doing this but uh here's
one more
let's let's watch answering me uh who
was just
sent to giving she came in like
[Music]
she's secretary
this may be hard to believe we don't
spend a lot of time talking about her
thinking about president trump here
former president trump uh
to be very clear is that the same woman
i think
is it the same woman did both of those
things she's a she is a terrorist
that is someone you know what i am end
everything i just said before
there should be a no-fly list and she
should be the only person on it
all right let's get now to our uh and a
no posting list how about that forget
about no fly list there should be a no
posting list
which which there already is with big
tech i guess i'm not innovating anything
new but
she needs to be on it all right um
let's go to reading the youtube comments
this is from magnum he says you're such
a cancer on society walsh
thank you sir uh another one says hey
matt i'm in high school wrestling we
aren't allowed to shake hands before
or after our match but we're allowed to
wrestle
thoughts on this
oh so yeah just for the sake of hygiene
and not
spreading germs around you don't want to
touch your hands but then you're going
to be draped all over each other
in the act of wrestling you know makes a
lot of sense
i i have to try we have to trust the
powers that be that it makes sense
we can't make sense of it because we are
our ma our pewdie
puny mortal minds can't quite process it
um another comment says matt which of
these three options seemed the most
likely
a reconciliation between the right and
left b civil war
c subjugation of the right by the left
i know you didn't you didn't offer a d
subjugation of the left by the right
because i guess we realize that ain't
happening
so between the two you know it
definitely
it is an a i think we know that
um another one says maybe i'll take my
mask off but i'll be damned if i'm
losing my anti-lightning sombrero
look you can never be too careful
frankly i think anyone who discourages
the use of an anti-lightning sombrero is
is
is actually murdering people you know
you are responsible when someone gets
hit by lightning
so very good very good uh point there
and let's see there's one other i want
to read um
okay jillian says matt yesterday you
said you'll wear a mask in certain
stores and tell your kids it's suppose
it's because you have to i was very
surprised to hear that i just recently
decided i won't wear a mask anywhere
this decision was after a recent
experience where my they told me my
eight month old had to wear a mask to
enter
i refused to give them any leeway like
you said it'll never end unless we
simply stop obeying these arbitrary
mandates
if we continue to comply they will
continue to enforce even more insane
rules oh yeah
never put a mask on a baby period it's
it's dangerous
eight i don't know who told you to put a
mask on an eight month old they should
be in jail
because that that could kill your eight
month old in fact um you don't put
things
at a child that age you don't put things
over their mouth
you know you're not even supposed to put
a kid in bed with a blanket at that age
so yeah you don't put a mask on a baby
i'm not gonna put a mask on
on little children um
i don't you know we don't i never
volunteer for masking we don't wear
masks outside we don't wear masks on the
playground
uh the only scenario in the past has
been my two
the oldest the seven-year-olds if we
have to run into a store real quick and
they're with me
and it's required to have a mask on then
i'll give them the mask and i explain to
them we got to just do this stupid thing
and we got to run in really quick
um but most of the time you know we'll
go in without the mask
if no one tells us to put on we won't if
someone who's not a position of
authority
in that store tells us we won't put it
on but if someone who works there
says can you put the mask on then we'll
do it just so we can get the stuff and
leave because the only other option
is to get into an argument with this
employee who has unfortunately has to
enforce this rule um
and then what we get kicked out of the
grocery store or something like that
and that to me doesn't seem like there's
any real point to it
um but generally yeah i i think we have
to get to the point
we should certainly all be the point now
where number one again wearing a mask
outside putting mask on your kid outside
is crazy don't do it um we shouldn't be
volunteering to wear the mask
but if you're in a private establishment
and someone who owns that establishment
says
you need to wear the mask or don't come
in then you know it is their rules well
you know mother's day
is uh right around the corner if you
didn't know that now you know i just say
i just saved your butt and i thought
i reminded you and uh so you got to
start thinking about what are you going
to get
uh your mom for mother's day what do you
get your wife for mother's day
well let me give you a suggestion a new
sponsor just in time for mother's day
the pearl source
at the pearl source you get the highest
quality pearl jewelry at
up to 70 off retail prices pearl source
cuts out the middleman by eliminating
traditional
five times uh markups by jewelry stores
and selling directly to you the consumer
so when you go to jewelry store and you
buy pearls or any other jewelry
you're spending way way way more than
you need to and that's what prosource is
all about
cutting out all of that extra baggage
they have the largest selection of
pearls available anywhere and each
jewelry piece is custom made
for you the pearl source offers fast and
free two-day shipping on every order
with zero contact delivery everything
comes beautifully packaged
in an elegant jewelry box so it's ready
to be given as a gift it comes with a
no-hassle 60-day money-back guarantee
so it's risk-free you don't want to miss
this don't overpay for jewelry go to
pearlsource and save it
to 70 off of retail prices and for a
limited time
listeners of my show can take 20 off
your entire order for mother's day so go
to the pearlsource.com
enter promo code walsh at checkout for
20 off your entire order on top of
the savings you're already getting you
just don't want to miss this if you want
to fi if you want fine pearl jewelry at
the best prices online
then go straight to the source the pearl
source pearlsource.com enter promo code
walsh at checkout
well another high energy episode of
candace is coming at you this friday
this week candace hosts political
commentator and
interviewer dave rubin they got a lot to
talk about including the recall election
in california caitlyn jenner jumping
into the ring so
that'll be an interesting conversation
subscribe now and stream candace live on
fridays at 9 pm eastern 8 pm central
only on daily wire
and remember if you're not a member you
can get 25 percent off a new membership
with code candice at dailywire.com
subscribe now let's get to our daily
cancellation
as we know people on the internet feel a
deep need to constantly be outraged
about things there's a certain amount of
outrage a certain quantity of outrage
that's required
to satiate this need as people you know
develop outrage tolerance though
they'll find that they need more and
more outrage to get their fix
now this shouldn't be a problem there's
no shortage of outrageous things
happening in the world all the time
you could no more run out of outrage and
you could run out of sand on the beach
but what happens
the problem is is what happens when when
the people who most need to feel
outraged
have also for political reasons
committed themselves to being
not outraged about the most outrageous
things
what happens when someone deeply needs
to be outraged but their ideology
precludes them from being outraged about
for example
the murder of babies and the general
mutilation of children
well this is like looking for sand and
you live right next to a beach
but you need to find sand everywhere but
the beach and even sand boxes
now you've just made what should be the
easiest thing incredibly difficult
that's why in the age of cancel culture
people are forced to go back in time
to find things to satiate their
outrage desires they gotta go back in a
time machine like back to the future to
find something to be
pissed off about every day there's
another video from years ago that's that
people are randomly upset about for no
reason other than the fact
that they need to feel upset about
something and this week
that video or one of them that fills the
need
is uh this it's an interview with steve
harvey from i don't know when several
years ago i think like 10 years ago
and in it he gives his opinion about
whether men and women can be friends
platonic friends
uh he says no and people are upset so
let's listen first to the as they say
resurfaced clip well my friends are men
i don't have female friends
i don't i'm i'm incapable of that
why what do you mean well because you
know come on because you have a wife
well i have a wife and i don't i don't
really have female friends because
look okay let's get rid of this myth
right here
okay i'm gonna tell you this let's get
rid of this right here that
you're an attractive woman there are
some guys somewhere saying yeah i'm
we're friends
no that's not true he's your friend
only because you have made it absolutely
clear
that nothing else is happening except
this friendship we have
we remain your friends in hopes that one
day
there'll be a crack in the door a [ __ ]
in the armor
and trust and believe that guy that you
think is just your buddy
he will slide in that crack the moment
he gets the opportunity
because we're going to think this way
99.9
of us think that way very upsetting
stuff there uh people are were upset
about it
also correct of course it's obviously
true that men and women can't really be
platonic friends
there are exceptions of course there are
exceptions to most general principles
okay but it's impossible to talk about
anything if we're not able to make
reasonable generalizations and we can't
that's why we can't talk about anything
because people are always
obsessed with the exceptions that's
another one of the pedantic things
people do online that annoys me
you're talking about general principles
and someone says no i'm aware of an
exception
i personally am aware anecdotally of an
exception let me tell you all about the
exception i know about
no this is a reasonable generalization
and it's true men and women can't be
friends that doesn't mean they can't
work together doesn't mean they can't
function around each other it just means
that they can't they can't be
buds they can't be pals in the same way
that
men can be pals with each other or women
with each other
now when talking about this subject the
first thing we have to say is and don't
take this the wrong way ladies but
um your opinion doesn't count okay your
opinion doesn't matter here it doesn't
matter what you say
and i'll tell you why i know that a lot
of you
think men and women can be friends but
it takes two to tango
and sadly men much of the time have an
entirely different dance in mind
as for men who claim that they have many
dear friends who are women
some of those guys are gay and the rest
are lying
don't shoot the messenger here i'm just
this is just the truth
now if you're the sort of person who
needs a study to confirm your own common
sense well luckily we have those
according to an article on the site
scientific american researchers recently
conducted an experiment
to find out how males and females in a
quote friendship
actually felt about each other so here's
how that went reading out it says
in order to investigate the viability of
truly platonic opposite sex friendships
a topic that has been explored more on
the silver screen than in science labs
researchers brought 88 pairs of
undergraduate opposite sex
friends into a science lab in order to
ensure honest responses
the researchers not only followed
standard protocols regarding anonymity
and confidentiality but also required
both friends to agree
verbally and in front of each other to
refrain from discussing the study even
after they had left the testing facility
these friendships friendship pairs were
then separated and each member of each
pair
was asked a series of questions relating
to his or her romantic feelings or lack
thereof toward the friend
with whom they were taking the study the
results
suggest large gender differences in how
men and women experience
opposite sex friendships men were much
more attracted to their female friends
than vice versa
men were also more likely than women to
think that their opposite sex friends
were attracted to them
a clearly misguided belief in fact men's
estimates of how attractive they were to
their female friends
had virtually nothing to do with how
these women actually felt and almost
everything to do with how the men
themselves felt
basically males assumed that any
romantic attraction they experienced was
mutual
and were blind to the actual level of
romantic interest felt by their female
friends women too
were blind to the to the mindsets of
their opposite sex friends
because females generally were not
attracted to their male friends they
assumed that this lack of attraction was
mutual
as a result men consistently
overestimated the level of attraction
felt by their female friends and women
consistently underestimated the level of
attraction felt by their male friends
what a shock and by that i mean
not a shock at all common sense wins
again this is so thoroughly confirmed by
common sense and the nearly universal
experience of all mankind
that it isn't interesting to talk about
whether or not it's true it simply
is what is more interesting to talk
about is why
it's true and the and the reason for
that is also a matter of common sense
though perhaps not so common anymore
it's this men and women are different
men and women no matter what they might
say for political and ideological
purposes
all basically know that they're
different they see each other as
different and they see each other
differently
you know heterosexual men are perfectly
capable of bonding with women but their
desire is to bond in a different sort of
way
and i don't just mean sexually a man's
attraction to women
is hopefully not merely sexual his
desire for companionship with a woman
has a prominent sexual element of course
but there's more to it than that
yet it all tends towards eros towards
romantic love
one of the problems i think we have in
society is that we only have one word
for love
rather than in other languages like
greek where they have multiple words for
different kinds of love
a man's affection for a woman is going
to be different in kind from the feeling
that he has about his male friends
he's going to want something different
out of the relationship that's not his
fault it's just not it's not a flaw or a
weakness it's perfectly natural he's a
man and as a man
he relates to women in a certain way now
notice something
women who think they have male friends
will often say that they're they're you
know
what they'll say is i'm just one of the
guys and they'll brag about how they can
throw down beers and spit and cuss with
the best of them right
most of the time that's a lot of silly
nonsense but even if it's true
you see how a woman who wants to be just
friends with a guy
will have to try to imitate the
relationship between two men she'll have
to try to blend in
with the guys she'll have to try and fit
herself into the category of a male male
friendship
be you know basically become a man by
default for the purposes of the
friendship
why is that well it's because there is
no authentic
category of a close male female
heterosexual
platonic friendship that category
doesn't really exist
the ones that work if they work at all
work because the woman is basically
pretending to be
a guy and is seen as a guy by the other
guys
but usually from the guy's perspective
if they want to hang out with guys
they'd rather the guys be actual guys so
if a guy is letting a woman into that
fold
if he is putting up with that charade it
is
usually for a reason and it's not the
reason that the woman has in mind
now the male female friendships that
really work are the ones that are
mediated and contained and centered
around some other larger thing
men and women can get along at work even
be friends in the context of work
married couples can be friends with
other married couples in these contexts
the friendship can function and remain
just a friendship
but they can't be close friends just
with each other
without that mediation and context
married couples can be friends but if
the husband from one couple
starts hanging out alone with the wife
from the other couple
problems arise as a wife
if your husband is out late having some
beers with his guy friend you might be
annoyed that he's out late but it's not
going to be a crisis in your marriage
if you find out that he's out late
having some drinks with a female friend
quote unquote they're going to be sirens
blaring and red flags waving all over
the place
in fact even if you didn't have any kind
of physical or sexual contact
with that woman at all you're probably
already gonna feel
cheated on because he should not be
having that kind of
intimate companionship with a woman who
is not you
he guys have a need for female
companionship
but it's a different kind of
companionship and so his need for female
companionship is supposed to be filled
by you he shouldn't need more close
female companionship if he does that's a
major problem
and ever almost every wife on the planet
sees it that way
even if for whatever reason they would
disagree with steve harvey on the point
he made
um there's no need to talk about whether
things should be this way things just
simply are this way men and women are
different they relate to each other
differently they bond differently
and that's fine you know the reality
only becomes a problem
this is this is a a general lesson for
everybody with in all things
reality only really becomes a problem
when you are set on denying it
and that's especially the case with
things with human nature
and we are set on denying so much about
human nature and that's why
everything is falling apart and all of
these things that should work
basically fine don't work anymore
because we're set on denying what is
obviously true right in front of our
face
and that is why well i don't need to
cancel male female friendships because
they don't really exist
uh instead i'm just going to cancel the
people upset about steve harvey
especially because that was something
from 10 years ago anyway so let's let's
keep let's get we're looking for outrage
can we at least keep it within the last
i don't know there should be a 30-day
cut off can we can we agree to that
all right we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadosky
the show is edited by sasha tolmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by nika geneva and
our production coordinator is mckenna
waters
the matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 21.
today on the ben shapiro show joe biden
unleashes an interminable soporific
address to congress and puts america to
sleep
while preaching insane radical leftism
that's today on the ben shapiro show
give it a listen